monsieur pourquoi pensez-vous que les
femmes se maquillent le visage et il y
en a qui se trouvent trop moche pour
être plus belle et sédire les hommes
pour être plus belle pour se montrer
davantage elle s'affirme de plus en plus
c'est une belle ponctuation je trouve
pour pour les femmes moi je crois que
c'est soit pour
plaire autour d'elle ou pour se plaire
ou pour chercher à plaire pour se plaire
à elle-même je dirais moi pour à
elle-même parce que le maquillage ça
peut aider à à améliorer entre
guillemets certains complexes oh bah si
elle a un visage jeune elle n pas besoin
de se maquiller mais enfin dès que
certaines rides apparaissent ou bien
certaines imperfections ben fait normal
qu'elle se maquille c'est pour pour être
plus jolie ou pour cacher quelqu des
fois imperfection parce qu'on a créé
plein de complexes chez elles et que du
coup bah elles ont besoin de les de les
cacher entre guillemets alors que si on
avait pas passé notre temps à leur
critiquer pour des petits défauts entre
guillemets ell auraient jamais eu besoin
de faire ça oui je dirais par crainte du
jugement crainte d'être soi-même une
femme qui a un visage naturel est
beaucoup plus belle qu'une femme au
visage maquillé parce qu'en fait le
maquillage n rien d'utre qu'un masque
moi personnellement j'aime pas trop ça
j'aime pas trop les gens qui se donnent
des identités avec du maquillage ou qui
se donne en fait qui se crée un visage
mais plus qu'autre chose pour se rendre
plus beau moi je pense que les femmes en
naturel c'est vraiment joli vous savez
au lever il y a pas beaucoup de femmes
qui puissent se vter d'être belle au
départ il y a des stars comme Alicia
Kiss qui donnent l'exemple en voilà en
disant que na pas besoin de maquiller
pas plus tard qu'hier ma mère m'a dit tu
devrais plus te maquiller moi
personnellement le maquillage des femmes
écoutez je trouve que c'est très joli en
ce qui me concerne moi j'en ai rien à
parce que je suis célibataire
alors vous comprenez ça me sert pas à
grand-chose si vous aviez plus tard une
fille qui est 15 ou 16 ans mettriez-vous
qu'elle se maquille non non non non non
non non absolument pas oui un petit peu
mais oui pourquoi parce que ça lui fait
plaisir ça met en valeur ses trait et ça
me choquerait pas bien sûr je lui
achèterai son maquillage même si elle en
a envie mais 15 16 ans je trouve que ça
va c'est ok pour ce matiller il y a pas
de bon il y a pas de souci non personn
après si c'est en si c'est mettre 3 cm
de couche sur son visage juste pour
aller en cours bon là ce serait un peu
abusé quoi bon moi je dirais 12 13 ans
oui c'est normal qu'on a envie de
s'affirmer à cet âge non une femme elle
est comme elle est on l'aime comme elle
est on l'aime pas par rapport à ce
qu'elle a sur la
[Musique]
figure